.
JILLIAN: LAMB BORE GENIE.
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI ON DEFENSE
AFTER CRITICISM OF HIS
CONSISTENTLY INCONSISTENT
MESSAGING.
>> WHAT THEY DIDN'T SEEM TO
UNDERSTAND IS THAT SCIENCE IS A
DYNAMIC PROCESS.
SO WHEN YOU HEAR SOMEONE SAY
SOMETHING AT ONE POINT AND THEN
TWO OR THREE MONTHS LATER IF YOU
STICK WITH WHAT YOU SAID AT THE
ORIGINAL TIME WHEN YOU HAD ONE
FIFTH THE AMOUNT OF DATA THAT
YOU HAVE NOW, I THINK THAT WOULD
BE INAPPROPRIATE.
BRIAN: DO YOU KNOW WHAT'S ALSO
INAPPROPRIATE YOU NEVER
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT YOU WERE
CHANGING YOU JUST WOULD CHANGE.
THIS AFTER NEWLY RELEASED EMAILS
SHOW A KEY WUHAN RESEARCHER
THANKED HIM FOR DOWN PLAYING THE
CORONAVIRUS LAB LEAK THEORY.
AUTHOR OF THE FORTHCOMING BOOK
"THE PRICE WE PAY" WHAT BROKE
AMERICAN HEALTHCARE AND HOW TO
FIX IT DR. MARTY MAKARY.
WHAT DID THIS EXPOSE TO A
MEDICAL EXPERT LIKE YOU.
>> I THINK WHAT WE NOTICED IN
THESE EMAILS, BRIAN, THERE IS AN
ABSENCE OF ANY REAL SENSE OF
URGENCY SOUNDING THE ALARM.
BY EARLY MARCH, JUST DAYS BEFORE
THE SHUTDOWN HIS STRONGEST
WARNING WAS SIMPLY TO TELL OLD
PEOPLE NOT TO TAKE CRUISES.
HUNDREDS OF LEADERS IN THE
UNITED STATES WERE EMAILING
THROUGHOUT FEBRUARY AND EARLY
MARCH BEGGING HIM TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT SHOULD THEY BE DOING?
HOW SHOULD THEY PREPARE?
SHOULD THEY TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY?
ABSENT WAS ANY REAL SOUNDING OF
THE ALARM WHEN MANY OF US WERE
AROUND THERE IS A HEY, A LITTLE
HELP FROM DR. FAUCI WOULD BE
APPRECIATED AS WE ARE TRYING TO
PREPARE THE COUNTRY.
BRIAN: ON THIS WHOLE MASK
DEBATE, WHEREVER YOU STAND ON
IT, WE KNOW HE FLIP FLOPPED ON
IT WE ALSO KNOW IN SCIENCE
MAGAZINE THAT CHINESE SCIENTIST
WHO IS A FRIEND OF HIS WAS
CRITICAL SAYING WHY AREN'T
AMERICANS BEING TOLD TO MASK UP?
AND THEN HE QUICKLY WROTE BACK
AND SAID TO THEM SORRY, THAT
REPORTER MESSED WITH MY WORDS.
I WOULD NEVER SAY SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
I THINK THE BIG STORY IS SHOULD
WE HAVE BEEN MASKING UP AND WHY
DID A CHINESE RESEARCHER HAVE TO
TELL A MAGAZINE WRITER THAT?
>> YEAH.
THERE IS SORT OF THIS HYPER
POLITE TIPTOEING AROUND EACH
OTHER'S FEELINGS AROUND THIS
ISSUE OF MASKING WHERE DOCTORS
IN ASIAN WERE WARNING AMERICAN
DOCTORS AND WARNING DR. FAUCI
CLEARLY IN THESE EMAILS TO
PLEASE TAKE MASKS SERIOUSLY.
LOOK, HE SHOULD HAVE KNOWN.
THIS WAS HIS RESPONSIBILITY.
SARS COV 2 SPREAD JUST LIKE
COUGH 1. COV 1.
BRIAN: HE KNOWS WHAT TO PUT IN
AN EMAIL.
WE SEE STUFF THAT'S CONCERNING
HERE.
IMAGINE IF HE WASN'T AS SKILLED
AS BEING A BUREAUCRAT AS HE IS.
>> DR. FAUCI HAS BEEN IN
GOVERNMENT FOR 53 YEARS.
ONE OF THE RULES IS ANYTHING YOU
PUT IN EMAIL IS PUBLIC
INFORMATION.
HE WAS CLEARLY VERY CAREFUL IF
THE MOST SCATHING EMAILS WE HAVE
ARE FROM PETER DASZAK TO HIM,
THEN WE KNOW DR. FAUCI WAS BEING
VERY CAREFUL.
I SEE THE ABSENCE OF DR. FAUCI
SOUNDING THE ALARM SENDING
WARNINGS TO LEADERS IN AMERICAN
BUYERS IN FEBRUARY AND EARLY
MARCH.
AND ALSO THE FAILURE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THEY NEEDED TO
PICK THE $40 BILLION IN TAXPAYER
FUNDING THAT GOES TO THE NIH.
THEY NEEDED TO PAY FOR THAT
QUICKLY COVID THAT WAS NOT DONE
UNTIL LATER IN THE YEAR.
BRIAN: DR. MAKARY, IS HE THE
BEST WE HAVE?
>> I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT HIS
TRACK RECORD IT'S A
DISAPPOINTING TRACK RECORD.
HILLS PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY IS
TO WARN US OF A PANDEMIC AND
TELL US HOW TO MANAGE IT.
BOTH THOSE PIECES OF INFORMATION
WERE IN A VACUUM.
WE DIDN'T GET THAT GUIDE DANCE.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED IN
A WUHAN LAB HE HAS BEEN ODDLY
QUIET ABOUT THE ENTIRE ISSUE
UNTIL VERY, VERY